Guten Tag, mein Name ist Altun. Ich bin auf dieser Station Assistenz-Asthetik und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Bevor Sie mir Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden erzählen, würde ich gerne ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Berger, Thomas Berger.
Thomas Berger. Können Sie bitte Vor- und Nachnamen langsam bezeichnen?
Mein Nachname ist Bertha Emil Richard, Gregor Emil Richard. Mein Vorname ist Thomas Theodor Heinrich Otto Maus Anton Ulrich Siegfried.
Danke Herr Berger. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 51 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 22. September 1974.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,78 Meter.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
112 Kilogramm.
Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie im Moment, Herr Berger?
Ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich seit mehreren Wochen und Monaten sehr müde bin.
Sehr sehr?
Müde.
Haben Sie andere Beschwerden?
Kopfschmerzen habe ich meistens auch. Ich bin auch oft gereizt.
Sie haben gesagt, mehrere Monate. Was genau haben Sie beschwerden?
Ich bin müde. Wie meinen Sie das genau? Wann oder wo?
Wann?
Seit mehreren Monaten schon. Ich kann nicht genau sagen wann.
Sind die Kopfschmerzen langsam oder plötzlich aufgetreten?
Sie sind immer wieder da. Sie sind nicht jeden Tag da. Aber immer wieder. Manche Tage habe ich nichts. Manche Tage habe ich mehr Kopfschmerzen.
Sind die Schmerzen irgendwann aus?
Nein.
Können Sie beschreiben, ob Sie Schmerzen haben?
Kopfschmerzen. Keine Kopfschmerzen.
Nur Kopfschmerzen.
Wo genau sind diese Schmerzen?
Überall.
Ganzer Kopf.
Aber etwas mehr hier hinten.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10? Wobei 1 sehr leicht und 10 sehr starke Schmerzen entspricht?
5.
Hatten Sie so etwas früher nicht beschwerden?
Diese Müdigkeit ist neu. Ich bin müde, sehr erschöpft und sehr gereizt. Manchmal habe ich auch das Gefühl, dass ich wenig Kraft habe.
Gibt es eine bestimmte Auslösung für Ihre Kopfschmerzen?
Weiß ich nicht.
Haben Sie Luftnoten oder Pusten?
Nein.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Gut. Sehen Sie an meinem Gewicht zu viel.
Wie ist Ihr Schlafen? Schlafen Sie gut?
Ich wache oft auf. Ich muss oft auf Toilette.
Wie oft?
Zwei Mal wache ich schon auf.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen?
Nein.
Heißrasen?
Heißklaufen?
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Schütterfrost?
Nachschweiß?
Kaltschweiß?
Ich schwitze manchmal, aber nicht so stark.
Gibt es Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder wie viel Stuhlgang?
Nein. Ich muss oft Wasser lassen. Abends. Zwei Mal mindestens.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten beim Laufen?
Laufen?
Ja, beim Gehen.
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ist Ihnen überg?
Nein.
Müssen Sie sich übergeben?
Wird Ihnen Schwierigkeiten manchmal vor den Augen?
Nein.
Oder haben Sie schon einmal Bewusstsein verloren?
Wie weit können Sie laufen?
Normalerweise.
Normalerweise?
Ich möchte Sie einfach fragen, um Ihre Vorgeschichte zu stellen.
Leiden Sie von einer Klinikerkrankung?
Ich habe einen Antipositas und bin ein Blutdruckpatient.
Blut?
Blutdruck.
Seit wann haben Sie Blutdruck?
Seit 10 Jahren.
Was sind die Medikamente?
Amipril und Amlodipin.
Amlodipin.
Wie viel dosieren Sie?
5 mg.
5 mg?
Ja.
Wie oft am Tag?
Morgens und abends.
Wie viel dosieren Sie amlodipin?
Beides 5 mg.
Morgens und abends.
Noch etwas?
Nein.
Transparenz.
Okay.
Noch etwas abends?
Ich habe andere Klinikerkrankungen.
Nein.
Würden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ich wurde einmal am Knie operiert.
Vor 10 Jahren.
Komplikationlos?
Komplikationlos, ja.
Warum Knie?
Warum?
Ich habe einen Knorpelschaden gehabt.
Entschuldigung?
Ein Knorpelschaden.
Knorpelschaden, okay.
Entschuldigung, seit wann wurden Sie operiert?
Vor 10 Jahren.
Okay.
Noch etwas?
Nein.
Haben Sie schon einmal einen Unfall gehabt?
Viele Unfälle.
Welchen Unfall?
Unfall mit Fahrrad.
Ah, Bermas.
Bermas.
Was ist genau die Problematik?
Was erwähnen Sie?
Probleme?
Während der Unfall?
Welche Probleme erwähnen Sie?
Ich habe mehrere Unfälle in meinem Leben gehabt.
Welche möchten Sie hören?
Ich verstehe nicht, was Sie meinen.
Ich habe jetzt keinen Unfall gehabt aktuell.
Okay.
Ich verstehe.
Mehrere.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne
Ihre Familie ein paar Fragen
zu Ihrer Familie stellen.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne
Ihre Familie ein paar Fragen stellen.
Leiden Familienangehörige
an eine wichtige Krankheit.
Also meine Mutter und mein Vater
sind verstorben.
Warum sind Sie gestorben?
Mein Vater hatte einen Schlaganfall gehabt.
In welchem Alter?
In 42 Jahren.
72 Jahre.
Meine Mutter
hatte einen Brustkrebs.
In welchem Alter?
Sie ist mit 75 Jahren verstorben.
Entschuldigung bitte.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschichten?
Nein.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig
Medikamente
außer Rheumatik,
Rheumatik, Amlotin ein?
Ja, ich nehme manchmal
Ibuprofen wegen Kopfschmerzen ein.
Kein Bedarf.
Kennen Sie Dosis?
400 Milligramm.
Okay.
Haben Sie
Allergien oder
Unfertigkeit? Nein.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr familialer Zustand?
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin geschieden.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe eine Tochter.
Sind Sie gesund?
Meine Tochter?
Ja.
Ist sie gesund? Ja.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Bürokaufmann.
Haben Sie Stress
bei der Arbeit oder im Privatleben?
Nein.
Den üblichen Stress nehmen.
Okay.
Treiben Sie Sport?
Leider nicht.
Herr Berger,
wie ist Ihr Status?
Sind Sie vollständig genügt?
Ich denke, ja.
Okay.
Wann waren Sie
im Urlaub?
Im Urlaub.
Wann waren Sie im Urlaub?
Im Sommer letzten Jahres.
Im Urlaub.
Wo waren Sie?
In Holland.
Okay.
Können Sie mir
beschreiben,
dass Ihre
Müdigkeit
in der
…
Was ist
Ihr Problem?
Genau.
Ihr Problem.
Ich hatte am Anfang es erwähnt.
Ich bin sehr müde
und
kraftlos,
sehr gereizt
und habe immer wieder Kopfschmerzen.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Blut?
Haben Sie Blut?
Hatten wir schon drückend besprochen?
Was glauben Sie, was ich habe? Ist das etwas Schlimmes?
Ich habe Sie wegen dieser Beschwerden informiert. Waren Sie beim Hausarzt oder bei der Hausesse?
Nein, noch nicht.
Herr Berger, ich habe vergessen. Rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche nicht, nein.
Trinkt ihr gerne Alkohol?
Sehr selten. Zwei, drei Mal im Jahr.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Drogen? Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ich nehme keine Drogen mehr.
Haben Sie früher geraucht?
Nein, noch nie.
Sie haben ein Depositat. Machen Sie Dirk gemacht?
Ich habe versucht, aber es hat nicht geklappt.
Ich habe alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt. Sie nehmen Platz. Warten Sie mal bitte.
Alles klar, danke schön.
Bitte schön.
Können Sie eine Frage stellen?
Hallo, guten Tag.
Kontrollieren Sie den Blutdruck regelmäßig?
Ist Ihnen die Knochenschwellen aufgefallen?
Ich habe in den letzten zwei, drei Wochen kontrolliert. Der Wein war sehr hoch.
Ich habe die Knochenschwellen nicht.
Danke schön.
Darf ich fragen?
Bitte schön.
Haben Sie Schlaftigkeit im Alltag? Sekundärschleif am Lenken, Konzentrationsstörung oder drückender Mund morgens?
Ja, habe ich. Ich schlafe auch schon seit mehreren Jahren.
Danke schön.
Noch weitere Fragen?
Herr Berger, wohnen Sie alleine?
Ich wohne alleine. Ich habe eine Katze.
Haben Sie Infektionsanfälligkeiten? Sehen Sie Probleme? Juckreis, Durst, Heißtunger?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Darf ich?
Bitte schön.
Wann haben Sie Schmerzen? Oft morgens oder abends?
Eher morgens. Bis Mittag habe ich Schmerzen.
Danke schön.
Haben Sie Herzrasen oder Brustschmerzen?
Nein.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen. Ich möchte Ihnen den Fokus vorstellen, wenn Sie es haben.
Der Patient ist Thomas Berger. Er ist 51 Jahre alt. Er ist 1,78 Meter groß und 112 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Berger, Sie sind seit mehreren Wochen und Monaten fatig und bedroht.
Er hat Schmerzen und Brustschmerzen.
Der Patient hat Schmerzen und Brustschmerzen.
Sie sind in der Oxypthal.
Die Frage nach der Diagnose war bis insomni.
Es war unaufwendig, dass der Patient beschrieben hat, dass er zweimal zur Toilette nicht mehr ...
... nicht mehr ...
... und manchmal Hyperhidrosis erwähnt.
Hyperhidrosis?
Schwitze.
Manchmal Schwitze.
Hyperhidrosis aber nur nachts, nicht tagsüber.
Nachts.
Eine generelle Hyperhidrosis.
Nachtliche Hyperhidrosis.
Nicht die Schwitzen kann man sagen.
Hyperhidrosis generell.
Anvor er kranken kann, nannte sie seit 10 Jahren Arterielle Hypertonik.
Er nehme 5 mg.
Er nimmt 2-mal die Hyperhidrosis.
Und 5 mg am Lodipin.
Bei ihm würde der 4. Seniorenknie operiert.
In der Familienanalyse gab es eher an, dass der Vater im Alter von 72 Jahren ein Apoplex verstorben sei.
Er hatte einen Myokardinfarkt.
Er hatte einen Mammarkarsinoma.
Er hatte keine Geschwister.
Er war ein Kind.
Er nimmt bei der Hyperhidrosis manchmal bei Bedarf 500 mg ein.
Allergien und Fertigkeiten seien nicht bekannt.
Er war ein Kind.
Er hatte eine gesunde Tochter.
Er arbeitete als Kaufmann.
Sie hatten viel Stress.
Sie trugen keinen regelmäßigen Sport.
Er war vollständig geimpft.
Reiseanalyse war unauffällig.
Er hatte eine Depression.
Er hatte ein Problem mit den Symptomen.
Er war allein im Alter.
Er hatte eine Adiposität.
Er hatte eine Erkrankung.
Er hatte ein Vorteil.
Manche sagen das nicht persönlich.
Ich habe nicht gefragt.
Wann ist er immer müde?
Morgens, Mittags, Abends?
Oder den ganzen Tag?
Ich verstehe.
Ich habe keine gefragt.
Meine Hauptbeschwerden sind ja die Müdigkeit.
Ja. Und die Kopfschmerzen.
Aber er hat ja gesagt,
Hauptbeschwerden sind, weil er seit mehreren Monaten Müdigkeit hat.
Dass er Konzentrationsstörungen hat.
Dass er gereizt ist.
Ja.
Was würden Sie denken?
Er hat ja nicht gesagt, dass er keine Lust am Leben hat.
Er hat nicht gesagt, dass er...
Ja, meine Verdacht Diagnose ist,
Schlappapneusyndrom.
Osas.
Schlappap...
...syndrom.
Apneusyndrom.
Wahrscheinlich Schlappapneusyndrom.
Was spricht dafür, dass er eine Tagesmüdigkeit hat?
Sie können ihn fragen beim nächsten Mal,
ob er tagsüber einschläft.
Ob er tagsüber schlafen muss.
Das müssten Sie fragen.
Die Kopfschmerzen sprechen dafür,
dass er keinen guten Schlaf hat.
Und dass er einen erhöhten Blutdruck hat.
Er misst jeden Tag und sagt, er hat 150 zu 80.
Das ist ein erhöhter Blutdruck.
Dass er nachts immer aufwacht, weil er auf Toilette muss,
ist auch ein Zeichen eines Schlappapneusyndroms.
Dass er adipös ist.
Das spricht nicht direkt für eine Depression.
Depression ist eher anders.
Hier würden wir eher gucken,
wahrscheinlich hat er ein Schlappapneusyndrom.
Und wie würden Sie denn dies diagnostizieren?
Was würden Sie machen für eine Diagnostik?
Ich würde sagen,
ich würde Schlaftests verhandeln.
Wie nennt man das?
Polyzomography.
Polyzomography nennt man das.
Ja, da kann man sehen, ob er Aussetzer hat, wie tief er schläft.
Bei der Untersuchung achte ich darauf Muskelton, eine Aufatmenfrequenz und dauert Atme und Schlafen als Kulve.
Und ist das was gefährliches?
Ja, es ist gefährliches. Diese Station ist gefährliches.
Das ist ein akutes Tod.
Plötzliches Herztod. Sie sind gefährdet für einen plötzlichen Herztod.
Was empfehlen Sie denn so einem Patienten?
Ich empfehle dem Patienten Gewichtsreduktion und Lebensstilveränderung, Nahrungsstiländerung und Psychotherapie.
Aber was empfehlen Sie ihm akut?
Akut?
Wie kann man ihm helfen? Eine Zepapstrahlung?
Ich erinnere mich an eine Medikamente, aber ich habe...
Kein Medikament? Da gibt es kein Medikament für?
Eine Zepapstrahlung für Maske.
Genau.
Sehr gut. Okay, haben Sie geschafft. Am nächsten Mal wird es besser.
Ja, danke schön.